this morning on the dish chef Mike
Randolph born in Cincinnati his start in
the industry was strictly entry level as
a soda jerk at a Michigan resort but he
loved the restaurant world and after
studying political science went on to
culinary school he worked at top spots
in Chicago but he hit his stride in st.
Louis with half-and-half specializing in
breakfast and brunch Randolph ease for
southern Italian and the latin-inspired
publico which this year earned Randolph
James Beard semifinalist honors as Best
Chef in the Midwest Mike Randolph good
morning welcome to the dish yeah it's
great to be here thanks for having me
tell us what we've got here sure so we
have kind of a meal inspired by stuff
that we would do it the restaurants
starting on my right we have some
roasted brussel sprouts really simply
served with a little bit of lemon and
shaved pecorino romano there's some
mushrooms shitake and hen of the woods
little balsamic vinegar kind of the
centerpiece here is a pork copa de copas
a muscle in the shoulder can be
difficult to find apparently they had to
call around he's an Italian butcher and
he knew exactly what it was and then for
dessert some torn biscuits some berries
and then a little sweet and marscapone
and it's all kind of cooked as a papaya
open it up garnish it and you're good to
stuff it in your face and this morning's
beverage is a rather interesting name
yes so it's kind of a poco de Prince
you'll have to bear with us a little bit
on that it's a smoke on Lake Minnetonka
and at the restaurant we're not has
adapted garnishing the cocktails at the
restaurant had started with what he
likes to call a raspberry beret uh-huh
you have three restaurants all of which
have very different focuses when you go
from one to one does your head spin how
do you keep them in order two of them
public own and Randolph ease are just
separated by about 60 feet so you know
through throughout the course of the
week I spent a good deal my my evenings
there and walking back and forth you
know one's very lively kind of a place
to be seen the other one is is very kind
of comforting kind of old-school Italian
supper club so it's a really cool kind
of dichotomy to walk 60 feet in walk
from one world into another yeah well do
you is it hard to develop the menu for
each or is it really live
reading to develop the menu for you it's
liberating my wife calls it menu land
it's just kind of where where I go off
to lay my is in many ways yeah exactly
so did you come from a sort of a food
family I mean I understand your aunt
punish too severe yeah k mom with fat so
I came from my father's side of the
family the Randolph east side was a
large Italian side and right yeah I
definitely have a memory of walking to
my aunt's pool party in my great aunt
Nettie and some of my grandfather
sisters throwing me in the pool because
I showed up with a bag of fast food hey
ya threw me in the pool those are some
on yeah but you know to answer your
question no I mean I really grew up
eating well done fillets and twice baked
potatoes for the first fourteen years of
my life and so it's like yeah so you
know once once I got out there you know
people have these great stories about
growing up peeling potatoes and the
restaurants like that wasn't the case
for me so you went to the New England
culinary school but you're headquartered
in the Midwest where the dining scene
has exploded recently yeah that was a
little bit more year in st. Louis why
not Chicago for example was sure I
metropolitan yeah I mean I definitely
kind of cut my teeth in Chicago and it's
it's an amazing place to cook and we
still my wife and i'll take the kids up
there and visit and I love Chicago when
we were looking at kind of trying to
strike out some identity on our own it
just seemed a lot simpler to go to some
place like st. Louis where there's a
handful of really good restaurant while
your wife is from where my wife is from
and that's how you get to st. Louis
you're either you're either born there
or you're married into it well sounds
like the marriage is more of a college
you know it's great st. Louis has been
very kind to me chef I'll ask you to
sign this dish as we always do on this
segment and I'll also ask you the
question we asked which is if you could
share this meal with any person past or
present who would it be sure well this
is probably a generic answer my father
passed away two years ago so I would say
my dad but if he was busy doing
something like maybe Washington is
watching a savior basketball game with
my brothers that I would say Bruce
Springsteen would be huh yeah
that is not a generic and not not at all
chef Mike Randolph congrats on all the
success all the project thanks for
joining a new restaurant one for more on
chef Randolph and the dish head to our
website at CBS this morning calm now
here's a look at the weather for your
weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]